Speaker 1: We have some potentially good news
about the infrastructure and spending bill duo,
and the news is that it appears Kirsten Cinemas
Office is saying and Senate Majority Leader Chuck
Schumer seems to be confirming that prescription
drug price controls may be back in the bill now.
On Monday, we played video and audio. I mean,
it'd be weird to just play video with no audio.
We played audio and video of Bernie being
interviewed over the weekend, Bernie Sanders,
senator from Vermont, saying, I'm still working
on the prescription drug price stuff, and
my hope is that we're going to be able to get it
in the bill. So let's look at what we learned in
the last 24 hours. Kirsten Cinema putting out
a statement cinema office statement on historic
Medicare drug negotiation agreement. A quote from
John Le Bombard, Kirsten Cinema's communications
director after Senator Cinema reached earlier
agreement with President Biden to include historic
Medicare drug negotiation in the reconciliation
package, policies that were admitted from the
initial framework at the request of members of the
House Speaker Pelosi reached out to Senator Cinema
this past weekend to continue negotiations. The
senator welcomes a new agreement on a historic,
transformative Medicare drug negotiation plan
that will reduce out-of-pocket costs for seniors,
ensuring drug prices cannot rise faster than
inflation. Save taxpayer dollars and protect
innovation to ensure Arizonans and Americans
continue to have access to lifesaving medications
and new cures and therapeutics. We also thank
representatives Peters and Schrader for their work
on this historic agreement. So there were
questions like What the hell is going on here?
We then heard from Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer agreeing they are doing this.
Let's go to some clips of Chuck Schumer.
Speaker 2: I'm pleased to announce that
an agreement has been reached to lower
prescription drug prices for seniors and
families in the build back. Better legislation
Fixing prescription drug pricing has consistently
been a top issue for Americans
year after year, including the
vast majority of both Democrats and Republicans.
Speaker 1: Continuing was Chuck Schumer to say
more specifics about what it is
that's been negotiated and the
direction things may be going here.
Speaker 2: By empowering Medicare to
directly negotiate prices in Part B and Part D,
this deal will directly reduce out-of-pocket drug
spending for millions of patients every
time they visit the pharmacy or doctor.
It will cap out-of-pocket spending of
2000 per year. Ending the days were a
life changing diagnosis could mean thousands
upon thousands of dollars in new expenses.
Speaker 1: OK, so some specifics there. And
then just a few more details here from Senate
Minority. Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
Speaker 2: and Senator Cinema, Right, has told
me she supports this agreement, so I think we're
there. It's not everything we all want. Many of us
would have wanted to go much further. Yeah, but
it's a big step in helping the American people
deal with the price of drugs, right?
Speaker 1: So I mean, listen, should we be happy
that something related to controlling prescription
drug prices is presumably going to be in the bill?
Yes. Yeah. I believe we can be happy about that.
That's OK. That's reasonable. Should we be furious
that this was even a debate and that it's one
of the many things in addition to paid leave,
more environmental regulate all the different
things we talked about Medicare expansion
that was pulled from these bills. Yes, it's
dystopian and disturbing that we're even having
these negotiations today. No question about that.
Should progressives still kill the bill, as I
suggested last week, maybe they should do. Listen,
you guys know that I'm the ultimate pragmatist.
In the past, I've taken heat for saying don't
kill a bill because it contains some good stuff.
Last week, I said the bills have now been
so gutted. Maybe it is time to kill the bill
because what we mostly have are sort of like
infrastructure, slush funds for corporations,
et cetera. And I said, maybe it is, and that a
bunch of people became furious for me saying,
yeah, real, pragmatic Pacman killing a bill
that actually has stuff in it that makes sense.
My position at this point is if this can be
passed soon in the next few weeks so that it's
truly done before the House and Senate recess
for the end of the year. And it does have
some climate related elements in it, and it does
have some worthwhile infrastructure spending and
it now has some, although not nearly what we would
like to see. Prescription drug price controls,
I say pass it, but I think whether the individual
bill is killed or passes as it would likely pass,
given what we understand about it now, it's not
going to be enough to save Democrats in 2022.
So on balance, would I rather some things
be passed than not? Yes. Yes I would. Is it
potentially even going to be like a pyrrhic
victory for Democrats to some degree? Yeah, it may
be. It's not going. I mean, listen, we looked at
what happened yesterday with the results. Passing
a milquetoast bill is not going to be nearly
enough to to motivate Democratic voters in a year
to vote in the November of 22 mid. Terms,
compared with the effectiveness that we know,
the fomenting of anger and the fomenting of
fear on cultural issues by Republicans will
have on their electorate. So pass the bill. Sure.
You know, I'm not going out there and saying,
kill it. It's just more an exercise in frustration
as to how long this has been going on and how much
weaker and weaker and weaker the bill is now. It's
gotten slightly less weak with the addition of the
prescription drug controls. OK. Pass it fine.
But if anybody thinks this is what's going to
save Democrats in 2022, oh no, no, no, no. And
yesterday's election results across the country
should be a reminder of that. We're going to take
a quick break. We'll have more coverage of this
on the David Pakman show Instagram, which you
can find at David Pakman show. You can find me
on Instagram at David Pakman. After the break,
we'll be talking about a new poll from the PRI
Public Religion Research Institute. I believe
it is telling us that 30 percent of Republicans
now openly support using violence to achieve
their political goals. My question is how many
support it but don't openly say it, so we'll talk
about that after the break. And much, much more.